sometimes movies arrived in theaters the
sound of a sad trombone they stink up
the joint for a while and then they
slink away in shame so the next time
you're having an off day your job just
be glad the results don't get released a
thousands of screens worldwide 2004 sir
grudge was one of the more well regarded
films of the wave of American remakes of
Japanese horror films that we saw in
that decade
unfortunately Hollywood studios are
apparently thinking that now is the time
to start rebooting all those remakes all
they did until the 2020 edition of The
Grudge crashed and burned hard enough to
give them second thoughts about
revisiting this particular franchise
it's had a promising pedigree with
Nicholas patch the filmmaker who broke
out with 2016 size of my mother writing
and directing and the cast that included
John Cho Betty Gilpin and horror legend
Lin Shaye what it didn't have wasn't
original plots a consistent tone or any
real scares
I'm scared to
poor Whittington of the independent was
one of the many critics tuba moan the
seeming lack of effort puts into the
film writing this is shoddy stuff full
of joy horror cliches and supposed jump
scares you can see coming a mile off
it's not particularly frightening but it
sure is depressing
virtually every critic acknowledged the
solid awesomeness of the cast but the
fact that The Grudge squandered their
talents only gave reviewers another
reason to trash the flick a sad fact is
that when they were already two other
better versions of this movie out there
that still hold up as icons of their era
this remake isn't just bad on its own
merits it's pointless to like a boss was
another film that utterly failed to
capitalize on the considerable talent of
its cast on paper the roster of talent
assembled for this mess is phenomenal
with salma hayek Billy Porter Rose Byrne
and Tiffany Haddish who seemingly cannot
catch a break when it comes her
cinematic outings don't hate me hate Mel
was her idea
burnin Haddish star as a pair of
up-and-coming business women whose
friendship is put to the test when
there's more cosmetics company is bought
up by a corporation it's a classic
comedy set up and this 83 minute kroner
made feeble stubs are both subversive
laughs and a hashtag goal buzz female
empowerment vibe neither of which worked
vultures Alison Wilmore put it best in
her review where she asked the same
question that everyone in the movies
Myka audience was left wondering how do
you make a movie with this cast and have
it be so devoid of joy it feels like a
film whose point has clumsily
misunderstood but the very people who
created it
that's brutal but accurate and Wilmore
wasn't alone Peter Travers a resident
film critic of Rolling Stone rated the
film at 1 out of 5 stars
and called it quote a comedy on life
support sorry to report the patient died
he is hoping Haddish burn in the rest of
this talented cast can a better
opportunity to show off their
considerable talent in the future after
being the face of the most popular
franchise in the world and getting the
most heroic death in recent memory at
the climax of Avengers endgame Robert
Downey jr. was probably in the rare
position of being able to follow his
11-year tenure as Iron Man with pretty
much any project he wanted to apparently
what he wanted to do with starring
Doolittle a retelling of a classic story
that baffled critics and required Downey
to sports one of the most impenetrable
accents in film history
nightmare the Guardians Peter Bradshaw
took a particular dislike of downey's
garbled dialogue delivery right saying
it really is horribly a nurse and every
time Downey opens his mouth to say
something unintelligible the film dies a
bit more it was he ready the machine
we're gonna need speed set up the core
the film's ugly slab - quality troubled
production and the poor special effects
were called out by a lot of reviewers
but the fact is this thing could have
looked like Avatar and celeb in a
disaster
more than one critic regarded down his
performance as a career worse which is
saying something when you consider that
he's had 40 years of starring roles
leading up to where that said it appears
that there was little that Downey could
have done to save a movie that was
simply ill-conceived and poorly executed
but hey following up a critically
acclaimed movie that virtually everyone
in the world saw with a universally
hated flop that nobody wanted is
certainly a bold move when it was
pitched the turning almost certainly
seemed like a great idea it's an
adaptation of the classic Henry James
novel the turn of the screw directed by
visionary filmmaker floria's Sigismond a
whose recent work includes critically
acclaimed prestige TV like The
Handmaid's Tale Runaways and American
Gods along with dozens of music videos
the cast was statue of Starr's Mackenzie
Davis of Terminator Doug Feith breakout
stranger things stuff in wolfhard
and Joe Lee Richardson fresh from a role
in 2018 stylish spy thriller red Sparrow
if that wasn't enough it was produced by
a guy you might have heard of called
Steven Spielberg with all that talent it
was bound to be stylish and most critics
agreed that it was they also agreed that
it was confusing boring and flat-out bad
I hope you know what you're doing those
obviously weren't the descriptors at the
casting crew and company were going for
and they got worse
David new saref real film reviews called
the turning quote an absolutely
abhorrent ghost story an excessively
deliberate drama that's almost entirely
devoid of dread and atmosphere an almost
and commonly intolerable contemporary
horror flick there was plenty of praise
for the actors with more than one
observer noting the projects wasted
potential for quite a few other sim
he deemed the film a waste it was
especially disappointing from a
filmmaker with a stellar track record
like Spielberg's Jamie east of the Sun
might have put it best and most brutally
writing at the man who gave us jaws and
poltergeist had even a smidgen of a
handedness relentlessly dull barrage of
cheap tricks is beyond me
utterly ridiculous and not worth your
time recycling the premise of the
classic campy 70s television series
fantasy island in which guests to a
mysterious resort run by an enigmatic
figure and their wildest dreams come
true into a plumb house horror thriller
was definitely a weird idea but not the
worst one we've ever seen sure the
series ended before most of the movies
target audience was even born
and was never that well-loved in reruns
but the sets up could certainly lend
itself to scarce and casting Michael
Pena in the mr. rockroll was nothing
short of inspired and fortunately the
flick from writer director Jeff Wadlow
didn't just botch the adaptation that's
real views James Bernard le put it
fantasy island 2020 made the campy
cheesy 70s TV original quote scene
smarts and fresh by comparison painfully
unimaginative Fantasy Island was one of
the most brutally reviewed movies of the
year critics call it convoluted
haphazard and stupid and those were the
kind of reviews the week story drew
complaints that it was an absolute drag
of a morality tale without the morality
that swapped out or the 70s cliches of
the original four equally cliche modern
horror tropes a revival of an old TV
property that nobody was actually asking
for can go very right sometimes just
check out the woefully underrated 2015
Man From UNCLE for proof this particular
fantasy on the other hand was more like
a nightmare and not in the fun scary way
that it should have been 2016 the boy
was an interesting horror effort and one
that wasn't really asking for a sequel
until the scares were over it was
intensively the story of a killer doll
who jealously guards the house in which
it lives where parents whose young son
tragically dies years earlier hire a
nanny to take care of their not so
inanimate boy the flicks shocking final
twist was one of the more well done in
recent years so leave it to its sequel
Brahms the boy to to essentially endure
it in the service of a far inferior
movie in the words of leave our person
you don't have to take our word for it
critic
William Bhavani wrote in the rap of the
movie swerves so hard from the good
parts of the first film that's quote it
practically leaves skid marks on the
screen many critics weren't even that
kind such as Benjamin Lee who wrote in
The Guardian that's quote there's
something willfully and scary about the
boy - as if director William Brent Bell
is trying to prove a point
shrine alight on the Shia pointlessness
of this kind of by-the-numbers genre
trash he also blasted the film for being
so barren of originality that it pulled
off the actually pretty impressive feat
of making an 86 minutes horror film seem
like an embarrassed ale snooze yeesh on
the bright side with as bad as this
movie was received it's pretty easy to
guess that the creepy dolls craters
victim was the chances of getting any
more sequels a movie centered on Jesus
Quint Anna from The Big Lebowski
she'll sounded like an interesting idea
star John Turturro
obviously thought so considering that he
poured a lot of persistence and a couple
decades into getting the character into
the spotlight with his own film 2020s
the Jesus roles which he wrote directed
and starred in unfortunately the film
leaned hard into the most cartoonish
aspects of the character and away from
the little things have made the Coen
brothers Lebowski a classic things like
nuanced humor a solid plot and dialog
that sounds like it could be spoken by
actual humans Bryant L arica of Roger
Ebert comm channel his site's namesake
calling the film uninteresting and
writing it turns out that the main
lesson here is that Jesus Quint Anna
shouldn't be going places outside of the
bowling alley
other reviews were equally harsh taking
aim at the lazy comedy of the screenplay
and the lack of originality and then
went on to rack up 10 frames worth of
bowling pants flick fees critic Franco
Chang went particularly hard on the
front leaving nothing to spare as he
framed up all the strikes against the
cinematic Turkey Jesus roles throws a
gutter ball down the farcical greasy
Lane in an imaginative sex buddy road
flick with a thin layer Juvenal
raunchiness is a strikeout of the
unwanted kind during the spin-off of one
of the most beloved cult classics of all
time after a full 22 years of
anticipation was probably doomed from
the start
but the Jesus roles would have been bad
no matter when it came out check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper video
but your favorite movies and TV shows
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and at the Bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]